hi and this is the second video i'm
showing the
the my gore
customer portal um
the first video we covered login
registration profile
the second video we're
going to skip over that and
look at the
do it online in my forms area
so i'm going to go ahead and log in
i'll just use the
login that i created in the earlier
video
yeah with me one moment
okay so i'm logged in
and you can see
in the header i've got my initial
showing
and my profile and whatnot as we covered
earlier um in the main
navigation bar
towards the top of the page
we've got my forms now that will only
show once you're logged in
until then you don't see it
um
so
i'll go through it online my forms and
bills and payments
thought online is our main
landing area um where all our different
forms and services are presented and
they're presented um organized by
category so
i scroll down a bit you can see we've
got 11 categories
and
there's a description with each one if i
drill into a particular category
such as alcohol
then
there's a list of
application forms to do with alcohol
again with descriptions
and we've got to have my forms on the
left as well now the my forms on the
left
will arrive at the same place as the my
forms that is available in the header
the difference is
the one the links within each category
will just filter down to only show any
forms related to that category
so i won't go into into all the
different categories but
what i want to do is
go through
filling in a form and um submitting it
and seeing
how that appears
in the my forms area
so i'm going to
choose symmetries and i'm doing a
application for an
internment
and
i won't i won't worry too much about
what the actual form is and what the
fields i'm filling out i'm just going to
go through this quite quickly
so you can see as they go through the
form
any step that i've completed goes to a
green tick the one i'm on is blue little
pencil icon and grey if i haven't
visited it yet
so we know where we're up to up to
applicants uh you can also see it's
filled in the
um
the name email phone number and post
address based on my user profile so
that's picked up from the data that i
entered on the registration form so
that's
uh it's a benefit for customers they
don't have to fill fill things in that
we already know about
so i'm just going to go continue
as we navigate through you can see
we've got back and continue at the
bottom
at the top there's a left and right
arrow that do the same function cancel
will
close the form and and throw away
anything that they've done there's a
warning before that happens
and save will
save a draft copy of the form so
the form is in a draft state until i get
to the font to the end of it and submit
it to council
um
and
you'll see that so if i partially fill
this in if i um
i type in the details of
the deceased
and then i click save
i'll give you a message saying that it's
been saved that's that's great
but now i could log out close shut down
my computer come back the next day log
back in
and if i go to my forms
um you'll see there's a draft area and
any forms that are that are partly done
will show in this draft
section so
um we can see what it is we can see the
reference number
um we've got a little draft badge on it
there's a couple of there's a dot dot
button there that gives me some things i
can do i can carry on where i was
i can create a duplicate so sometimes
you want to create a copy of a form
any duplicates that get created are also
in draft
and i can delete it which is the same as
the cancel option that we looked at
earlier
i can click on the on this whole card or
the view button that will drill in
the
drilling into a draft doesn't offer too
many different options we've still got
our duplicate delete continue
but it has this sharing option here and
sharing is where i want more i want
someone to help me fill in the
application form so we can set up
multiple logins to access the same form
so currently
i'm the owner
there's my details there
but i can invite someone else so i can
click on invite
i can type in a new email address
and
a message to the person receiving the
email
and then i can decide what permissions
this person that i'm inviting to have
access or have
um
so read is
is a minimum so that means they can view
it but if you want them to help you fill
in the form you would offer your tick
the update option as well so then they
can
they can um
fill in details on the form while it's
in draft but they can't submit the form
if they have update they have to have
the submit permission in order to be
able to submit um there's a cancel
permission
manage files is about being able to
upload files after it's submitted which
sometimes you want to do to provide more
information to council
and the manage access means that they
can control permissions for other people
so they can
you know on invite to a third person
potentially
typically you're just going to want them
to see it and and possibly update it
so i'm going to tick those two and i'm
going to click share
and
now we can see in this sharing table
um there's a second person
status is pending so they
will have received an email invite
but they haven't actioned it yet
and we can remove we can change their
permissions at any time we can resend
the invitation
so what that will have done is send an
email
to
my email address and
i'll just drag that email across so you
can see it
um again the wording can be configured
but what we're doing here is saying
that this application form
has been shared with you
and then to
to gain access to it you have a link to
click
and then there's we've also got the
message here that i typed into the
sharing
um
if i click the link it'll take me
through
the same login step that we looked at in
the first video
if they're a new user they would have to
register for the first time
but after having either logged in or
registered
they will there's a code in this link
that gets passed all the way through so
that when they eventually
have logged in they will see the same
form and dmi forms
um so that's how we have co-applicants
or co-authors of applications
all right so i'm just going to
go ahead and continue
[Music]
my application form so
again this doesn't have to be all the
same session the benefit of having a
login and
saving is that i can
come back at any time
in a different session and just pick up
where i left off
which is exactly what i'm doing
um
i'm going to um
go through this fairly quickly most of
the fields are not needed very luckily
next um can
it's mandatory
um
and so on
hmm
all right so
i've got through
filling in all the details of the form
it's now telling me what my fees are
so you may not have the step if the
application doesn't require
um a payment for its paid
in arrears at a later date um but in
this case we're saying yep you've
calculated your fees and
um please pay your money
so i could be
paying that in person at council or via
internet banking
but i can also
pay immediately
using a credit card or debit card
um
so there are other options like poly
if you choose credit or debit card then
this is
gateway so it's a it's a separate system
that's fully pci compliant
um
details are not exposed
anywhere they shouldn't be
um
i'm just putting in a
test
card number
and you'll also see that there's a
service fee of 33 so there's a there's a
percentage fee that gets applied which
customers want about in advance
that's covering bank
fees largely and doesn't go to council
so
that's successfully made it's that said
thanks we've got your application here's
your reference number
is what happens in terms of your payment
and we will have sent an email as well
with details of
details of what of the application and
also a an invoice receipt
but if i go to
[Music]
the my forms area
so you'll see it's disappeared
from draft the application that i'm
working on because i've submitted it
and
we've got two other statuses that we
filtered by here there's open forms and
there's closed
um
now which whether it's open or closed
depends on the status um so this has
gone into a status of meeting the status
is a configurable per form so they might
vary but
um
typically you you
any application that's going through
processing will have a vetting or
processing or you might even just say
submit it um
once it's been um fully processed and
approved or declined or whatever has
happened to it
it'll go into a final status which might
might be say granted or approved or
whatever
at that point
that will move it into the closed area
so close will show history of things
over time that are that have been dealt
with and are complete open should be the
ones that are
um currently in processing so the line
the ones that the customer is likely to
be interested in
by the way over on the right here we've
got a couple of icons that just toggles
between a
list view we all applications just show
on a table
and this card view the card view is the
default it's a bit more mobile friendly
because you you can sort of tap anywhere
in the card with your finger um and a
bit more modern the list view might be
useful
um
more on a pc or a notebook
and
useful for
often for companies that might have lots
of applications if you're a building
company or so on
um directly most people will be fine
with this view
right so if i um i drill into this
application um that's been submitted and
is now investing so you'll see it's got
a few more options
um we've got a summary
page this can have more details about
the application that's a configurable
choice and it will show milestones as
well so we'll show what date it was
created when it was submitted to council
and any status changes
will show here as well so we can see
it's gone into vetting on this date
in the dot dot menu we've only got
duplicate um
that can be quite handy if you've got
something like an event permit that's
for an annual event and it doesn't
change too much year on year you might a
customer might come and find last year's
um permanent application and and go
duplicate and then they've got a new
draft that they can
um save a bit of time on because most of
the data will already be filled out
um down the left here we've got our sort
of main menu for the detail of this form
so attachments will show any files
now it might be that the customer has
uploaded a file as part of the form so a
lot of forms require require files to be
attached with them
and
um i can also upload new files here so
there's a
there's an upload file button um
maybe
council have asked me to supply some
more details
um maybe i've been asked
to supply a death certificate um and
you can click
the browse button or
as i'm going to do you can find
a suitable file
and
just drag it
into
that area it will upload the file
it will virus scan it
tell the user whether it's successful or
if there was an error it was a virus
um
and then you just click okay and then
that will show here so you can see at
the top here there's a from console
heading at the top of each of these
files but the one i just uploaded there
isn't so
you can tell which ones which files are
attached by the council which were
attached by the customer
in terms of the two council files we've
got a copy of the submitted form so by
default any application form that you
fill in online
will get a pdf created capturing all the
or showing all the data that um
that has
been entered in the form if i just
download that you'll get an idea it
looks something like this
um so this will you have all the things
that i've filled in
and
we
typically will email that to the
customer as well for their records
um as well as having it available at all
times in the portal
if there was a payment made then there's
typically a
an invoice receipt as i said before they
get sent to the customer that might look
something like this that tells their
fees and the fact that zero dollars
owing so they know
that's all paid
and any other files that get added by
council so you might upload a an
approval letter in the admin site
and then the customer will see it here
as well
if that happens you might
email the customer with a link to this
page so that they can come in
and get to it anytime
um the bills and payments area
is around the you know any financial
aspect of the application form if there
is one so this one does have fees so we
can see the fees here
um we can see that there's no money
owing
there's an invoice that got created
there's another download link to it here
as well as being under attachments and
we can see the payment made by credit
card
and when it was made
so we know there's no money owing that's
all good
history will show um
uh sort of an audit trail of events so
when it when it was created through
different status changes and it's also
captured that i've
uploaded that extra file
um so it's visible to everyone what's
what's happened when and again you've
got sharing so
um this one is still shared but
um
from the draft but i could also add
someone else maybe with a few
permissions at this point
so they can see
the submitted application and they can
see the status
and the status changes that it goes
through with council
and potentially you might also
share it with someone and allow them to
upload files after submission
now what i'm going to do next is
just jump into the admin site you won't
see this happening but i'm going to um
i'm going to open the file as a
yeah as a council processing officer and
i'm going to
just um
complete my vetting of the application
which won't take a moment
and
uh
i am
going to
complete my vetting and say that it was
accepted which i've just done
and
back here in the customer portal
if i refresh this
page here so you can see the status has
changed to processing and we've got an
extra step in our summary
also back in the
in the open forms list we can see it's
changed the processing there as well
now
the other thing i'm just going to do is
i'm going to go into the admin site and
add the fact that there's some extra
money going
um
so
i'm just going to add a um an extra
processing fee so that for whatever
reason
customer owes some more money
and
i have
just done that now
so if i drill into this application
and go to
bills and payments you can now see that
there's a hundred dollars owing and
there's a debit note so we've
added some extra fees if i go down to
the charges there's my extra fee that
i've just added
and now i i have the option to pay now
um so typically an email will have gone
to the customer as well but
um i can
through the portal
and probably throw a link in that email
as well i can end up in this
this
form here where um i can come in and i
can pay for
that extra hundred dollars by credit
card
or debit card
um
i won't bother doing that just now but
um
you can see
also on the card back in the in the
top level open my forms um it shows
quite clearly that that's got some money
on it owing on it as well
um
well also if i go into bills and
payments you'll see that there's
um that hundred dollars will show there
isn't as an outstanding bill
um it's due immediately which i had
something's gone into the due due today
um and it will also shows overdue once
it's over june
um and any um any fees that the customer
you might show in this view as well
so that's
my forms i could take this form into a
completed state and it will go into
closed but i won't do that
also on the dashboard
we show the three any three
upcoming bills so
when they first logged in if there's
something that's that's due imminently
they'll they'll see it there as well
um and we've got a link here to see all
bills and payments which just goes to
this builds and payments area
um
if there was nothing to pay
in the you know in the card view we've
still always got these three links up
here that's paying invoice pay property
rates pay waterville and in fact if i
wasn't even logged in so i'll just log
out
and then i go to bills and payments
you'll see those links are always there
so
these are are there to allow people to
pay money to council either for an
invoice
um or for their rates or for their water
bill
and depending on what it is if i if i go
to pay an invoice i have to enter an
account number on an invoice number
um and then it'll go and check and show
me the amount to pay and go through my
payment so you because i'm not logged in
it doesn't know
what my bills are what invoices i owe
it's i have to identify what it is that
i want to pay in this first step
similarly with pay rates
you enter an address
or evaluation number or an account
number
so these options might change they're
configurable
you search for your particular address
find it and then
you can go to paying
paying an amount in the second step you
do have to choose what amount you want
to pay for rates so with for privacy
reasons we don't show
um
how much is owing on a rates account
because anyone can enter any address and
see it so
it's up to the customer to know what
they owe or what they want to pay and
put they don't on the second step
so um i won't go through that um
so that um that wraps up what i wanted
to show in this
second video we've been through um
through looking at the different things
you can do under do it online
creating a draft form submitting it
paying some money seeing it move through
different statuses
and doing some anonymous payments as
well so
that's the main functionality of the
portal
and we will pause there thank you very
much